- Unsere Öffnungszeiten?
Wir haben von Dienstag bis Sonntag von
neun bis 23 Uhr geöffnet.
Am Montag haben wir leider geschlossen.
Ja!
Danke!
Tschüss!
- Magst du noch eine Limonade, Nico?
- Ja, ich nehme noch eine Limonade.
- So! Es ist zwölf Uhr.
Das Mittagsangebot beginnt jetzt.
- Ja!
- Was gibt's denn heute?
- Heute gibt es Rouladen mit Rotkraut
und Kartoffeln
oder Fisch mit Gemüse
oder die türkische Linsensuppe.
- Vielleicht nehme ich die … den Fisch
Nein, die Suppe …
Oder warte!
Die Rouladen, ich nehme die Rouladen.
- Sicher?
- Bitte schön.
- Danke schön.
Entschuldigung, wie viel Uhr ist es?
- Es ist zwölf Uhr.
Du wartest auf Lisa, oder?
Kommt sie um Viertel nach zwölf
oder um halb eins?
- Um halb zwölf.
- Oh, normalerweise ist sie pünktlich.
- „Das Marek“. Hier ist Tarek.
Hallo, Lisa!
Nico?
Ja, der ist hier.
Okay. Ich sage es Nico.
Bis gleich! Tschüss!
- War das Lisa?
- Ja. Sie kommt um Viertel vor eins,
also um 12:45 Uhr.
Ich meine, sie kommt in 45 Minuten.
Das Bewerbungsgespräch dauert länger.
- Okay, ich verstehe.
- Ich bin übrigens Tarek.
- Hallo, ich bin Nico!
- Oh, Nico, kannst du mir helfen?
- Ja, gerne.